[Music]
Hannity joining us now to react my
opening monologue tonight former Speaker
of the House author of now 12 weeks in a
row New York Times best-selling book
including number one understanding Trump
former Speaker of the House Newt
Gingrich also a Fox News contributor
let me start we have a lot of issues to
get to that let me start with the
revelation about James Comey he the fix
was in he knew he had no intention of
talking to the witnesses getting the
facts and then coming to a conclusion
and it's like okay admitting that we
have a two-tier justice system how do we
handle that essentially we had a lot of
talk about obstruction of justice we've
now found out who is obstructing it was
the director of the Federal Bureau of
Investigation and as Andy McCarthy's
pointed out in a very fine column the
person who really led the effort was
President Obama who back in April of
2016
outlined the case for Hillary being
innocent and it's exactly the case that
company leaders a lie as I mean you've
never seen I mean had to figure I mean
interruption but I read McCarthy's
column and like you have a lot of
respect for nd I really do and I saw the
quotes Obama let her off the hook by
saying it didn't impact national
security but wait a minute didn't the
FBI director go through this painstaking
process of reminding us that he had to
remind Trump President Trump that the
Department of Justice and FBI were
separate and apart from the
administration why wouldn't that apply
here of course let's let's start with
James Comey is a liar and he's in the
middle of telling a lie and the lie is
pro-hillary and anti-trump that's the
beginning of the whole story Republicans
as I see it have September October
November in two weeks of December to get
an awful lot done I've laid out what I
think should be accomplished your
thoughts well I think you're basically
moving in the right direction I would
say that they have to avoid shutting
down the government because they're seen
as the people in charge they have to get
a tax bill through they have to cut
taxes to get this economy growing I
think they should get the wall funded
and they should get the dreamers taken
care of those are minimum things there
are steps
they have to take on dismantling
Obamacare because the system's just
going to unravel so my guess is you
actually to everyone's surprise going to
see some stuff move on health care this
fall but you're right they've had eight
months to not get it done they've now
got a very short time and they're going
to have to be productive if they're
going to survive the 2018 election all
right we now have a situation with North
Korea they're firing missiles over
Islands that obviously are owned by the
Japanese we have shown them we could
take these missiles out of the sky
they seem Dow they've got their first
nuclear test or the second but it's been
a long time since they tested one what
should we do next I think the only
solution is to start firing their
missiles out of the sky or off the
launch pad yeah I think we have to adopt
a new doctrine that the the mutual
assured destruction doctrine that worked
in the past doesn't work with these
people they clearly are going to go
their own way they're going to do what
they want to do they operate off of a
logic very different than ours
and I think we have to say we're not
prepared to risk losing an American city
we don't have to preempt them we don't
have to start a war but we should
announce that any missile that is
launched that has not been inspected by
the American government and is not
certified by us to not have a nuclear
weapon on it will be automatically
killed as it starts to rise we need a
system where between lasers and
hypersonic missiles we literally can
kill it on the way up then we need a
system of killing it at the apogee and
then we have already a system of killing
it on the way down but we need a layered
defense we need to calmly start
executing that tell the say look you
don't want to start a war but we are not
risking an American city because we have
no trust in Kim jong-un I think that's
well said but as we said at that point
there's no good solutions let me go to
doc again this from the beginning even
though President Obama admitted it was
unconstitutional he then who served the
authority and power of Congress the
president is now given Congress eight
months to deal with that issue that
have an additional six months is this an
issue we're constitutionally when we
talk about co-equal branches of
government and enumerated powers is this
something that must be done if we want
the rule of law to work in this country
sure look I thought president Trump and
I know he worked on this for several
weeks because he was trying to find a
way to honor the Constitution and have
compassion and I think he came up with a
solution that's totally legitimate he
said okay clearly it's illegal but
there's a practical reality something
like 760 thousand six hundred ninety
thousand people actually in the system
now but seventy thousand still being
processed we're not going to cut them
off the compassion would not allow us to
cut them off but that means Congress in
the next six months has to do its job
now I think everybody who's upset or to
call their senator and their House
member and get them to pass the
codification of daca into law so we can
both have the Constitution and
compassion I think it is totally phony
for liberals to complain about President
Trump who has kept his word who has
really bent over backwards to help the
dreamers and I think you today once
again express how committed he is to
trying to help these young people mr.
speaker thank you appreciate it as
always well